Or that we do not unite,
allow,
Huh?
Have 1 environmental bomb placed
in the Galician countryside,
such as the macrocellulose of altre,
1 project
about what they lied,
misled and withheld information,
both this parliament and the citizenry,
the company that promotes this project.
It is Portuguese.
If it is so excellent,
why don't they want that one in Portugal?
Do you know why?
Because it is 1 polluting project,
no mimes,
to allow us to be Colen as industrialization,
o that 1 huge environmental property
that I would consume more and more drowning every day
that every population in the province of Lugo
e above,
subscripted
with 250 million euros from everyone.
Industrializing Galicia,
yes,
contaminate galiza and enrich
or future,
the following seraci,
no, Mr.
Wheel